Speaker 1: Republicans in Arizona wasted
no time claiming fraud yesterday. There
is absolutely nothing to this, but they
wasted no time claiming fraud. Charlie Kirk,
who lives in Arizona and was very involved with
the Kerry late campaign and Blake Masters tweeting
out to our wait minimum at most polling places in
Maricopa. Democrats running elections here knew
this would happen. Traffic jam by design. Don't
let them do 2020 again. Wait in line and vote.
It turns out actually that Democrats don't
run elections in Maricopa County. The Board of
Supervisors is four Republicans and one Democrat.
Same thing with the county recorder. 2020 was safe
and secure in Arizona, but they were starting
to catch up on this Arizona stuff. Here's Brett
Beyer saying it's a little suspicious over there.
Speaker 2: We kind of knew that this election was
going to happen. You know, I mean, maybe we've
been getting ready for for a while. How about how
about we fix the machines? I mean, why is this
happening? Can we get our head around? There
are going to be problems all over the country,
some problems. But for it to happen here, for
it to happen now in this way is kind of strange.
Speaker 1: No. Well, what you have to remember
is it's not that it's happening. It's
that Republicans decided we're going to
say that there's fraud in Arizona. Really?
There were no waits or very short waits in
most places. Residents are allowed to vote at
any polling place they want, not just the one
nearest their home. And there's a very good
NPR piece. Arizona's Maricopa County says
its identified a solution for voting equipment
issues. There was an issue with a tabulator.
It was dealt with. It was not a huge deal. But
rest assured, if Carrie Lake loses, she's losing
right now. But we have to wait until all the
votes are counted. If Carol Lake loses, she will
say it was fraud. Let's take a quick break and be
right back with a very, very busy news day today.
I know it's almost too soon to even say this, but
the 2024 election is on and you will see in the
next six days just how quickly it ramps up. We
have a new coupon code 24 starts now which you
can use at join pacman dot com. I would love for
you to sign up on my website and become a member